,
ARIZONA, AND BEYOND.
HE FOR REACTION, THE PRESIDENT
OF THE NATIONAL BOARDER PATROL
COUNCIL, BRANDON JUD, AND
ARIZONA ATTORNEY GENERAL MARK
BRONOVICH, I CAN'T EVEN COUNT
THE NUMBER OF TEAMS I'VE SEEN
YOU BOTH ON FOX NEWS TALKING
ABOUT THE BORDER.
ONE'S THE ATTORNEY GENERAL,
ONE'S IN THE BORDER PATROL, YOU
LIVE IT YOU BREATHE IT.
TESTIFIES TO CONGRESS THAT THE
BORDER IS SCAR.
BRANDON JUD, IS IT SECURE?
>> I ABSOLUTELY NOT.
LET ME GIVE YOU EVIDENCE.
NOTICE THAT SECRETARY MALLORCA
WON'T GIBB YOU EVIDENCE.
WE'VE HAD MORE THAN MILLION
PEOPLE CROSS OUR BORDER
ILLEGALLY AND HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
ABLE TO EVADE APPREHENSION.
THAT NOT NOT A SECURE BORDER.
WE HAVE HAD MORE FENTANYL ACROSS
OUR BORDERS TO MAKE IT INTO OR
STREETS AND KILL OUR CHILDREN
THAN EVER.
THE CARTELS ARE GENERATING A
RECORD PROFIT.  THAT'S IS NOT
SECURE BORDER.
EVERY SENGAL IN THAT WE'RE
SEEING ON OUR BORDER CLEARLY
POINTS TO THAT THERE IS ABSOLUTE
CHAOS, THAT THERE IS A CRISIS.
IF THIS ADMINISTRATION IS NUT
WELLING TO DEFINE WHAT IS
CURRENTLY GOING ON, THEY'RE
NEVER GOING TO TRY TO LOOK FOR
SOLUTIONS.
THAT IS THE PROBLEM THAT WE
FIST.
THIS IS A B BAD GOVERNANCE THAT
WE'RE SEEING BY THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
>> MR. ATTORNEY GENERAL, THE
SECRETARY OF HOMELAND SECURITY,
DESPITE ALL THOSE NUMBERS THAT
BRANDON JUST BROUGHT UP, SAYS
THE BOARDER IS SECURE.
WHAT'S YOR THIS PRESENTATION OF
SEC REPLAY IS PRESENTED BY DR.
PEPPER, THE ONE FANS DESERVE. --
WHAT YOR REACTION AND
PERSPECTIVE FROM THE STATE OF
ARIZONA?  SHANGHAISEN, EVERYONE
IS ENTITLED TOOTHIER OWN
OPINION, AND NOT THEIR OWN
FACTS.
WE KNOW THE CARTELS HAVE SEIZED
OPERATIONAL CONTROL.
I THINK WHAT SOMETIMES IS MORE
DANGEROUS IS THIS PROGRESSIVE
LEFT THAT SEIZED CONTROL OF THE
BIDEN WHITE HOUSE THAT IS
LITERALLY LYING TO AMERICANS AND
PEOPLE ARE DYING AS A RESULT.
JUST TO PUT INTO PERSPECTIVE,
SINCE JOE BIDEN BECAME
PRESIDENT, ENOUGH PEOPLE
ILLEGALLY CROSSED OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER TO FELL THE STATE LIKE
ALABAMA OR LUISE AN A.
ENOUGH FENTON AL IS BEING SEIZED
TO KILL EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN
THE UNITED STATES, AND THAT'S
WHY WE'RE SEEING A RECORD AMOUNT
OF PEOPLE DYING, MORE THAN 100
THOUSAND PEOPLE LAST YEAR ALONE
IN THE UNITED STATES.
BORDER SECURITY IS NATIONAL
SECURITY.
AMERICA IS LESS SAFE, OR CITIES
ARE MORE DANGEROUS AS A RESULT
OF THE IT'S TAKEN WAY TOO LONG
FOR CONGRESS TO FINALLY DO
SOMETHING AND I'M HOPING NOW
THAT HAD REPUBLICANS CONTROL
CONGRESS, THEY WILL MAKE SURE
THE SECRETARY MALLORCA AND JOE
BIDEN ARE HELD TO ACCOUNT.
IF A THAT MEANS IMPEACHING HIM,
SO BE IT.
>> IMPEEPMENT MAY BE THE VERY
ANSWER, THE ONLY ANSWER THAT
LEFT AT THE TABLE HERE.
YOU LOOK AT THAT THERMAL IMAGING
VIDEO THAT FOX SHOT, HOW IS THAT
NOT AN INVASION OF OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER?
THAT NOT A SECURE BORDER.
THAT IS AN INVASION THAT I'M
LOOKING AT RIGHT THERE FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE.
BRANDON, THE SECRETARY'S TRYING
TO BLAME THIS ON MIGRATION
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE WESTERN
HEMISPHERE.
I CAN'T NAME A SINGLE COUNTRY
OTHER THAN THE UNITED STATES
THAT THESE PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO
FLOCK TO.
>> OF COURSE HE'S GOING TO
ATHAT.
HE'S GOING TO DEFLECT FROM HIS
FAILURES.
HEY HAS DONE SUCH A POOR JOB IN
HIS OFFICE.
YOU TALK ABOUT AN INVASION AND I
AM GRATEFUL TO ATTORNEY GENERAL
BRONOVICH BECAUSE HE'S TALKED
ABOUT THE INVASION BEFORE.  THIS
IS ORGANIZED.  THIS IS BY
CARTELS THESE ARE CRIMINAL
ORGANIZATIONS, THAT ARE VERY
ORGANIZED AND THEY'RE SEND
LAGGERRING ALL THESE PEOPLE
THEY'RE SENDING THE FENTON AL.
THAT IS IN FACT AN INVASION.
I BELIEVE THAT'S WHAT TEXAS JUST
DID I THINK IT WAS THE RIGHT
MOVE EVEN THOUGHT GROWING TO GET
CHALLENGED I BELIEVE THAT THE
SUPREME COURT WILL IN FACT HOLD
UP THEIR DETERMINATION THAT AN
INVASION IS TAKING PLACE BECAUSE
IT IS BEING DRIVEN BY ORGANIZED
CRIME.
>> MR. ATTORNEY GENERAL, WE HAVE
A SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME.
IS IT AN INVASION?
>> YEAH, WE ACTUALLY ISSUED A
FORMAL LEGAL OPINION SAYING WHAT
IS GOING ON ON OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER DOES CONSTITUTE INVASION
PEOPLE CAN GO READ THAT OPINION.
IT'S VERY WELL-RESEARCHED AND
WHERE DO AGREE WITH BRAND THAN
SUPREME COURT SHOULD UPHOLD THIS
BECAUSE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IS SUPPOSED TO BE DOING THIS.
IF HARE FAILING TO DO THEIR JOBA
THE STATES HAVE THE RIGHT TO
DEFEND THEMSELVES.  THAT WHAT
GOVERNOR ABBOT'S TRYING TO DO.
>> BRANNON JUD, ATTORNEY GENERAL
BRONOVICH, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
LAYING OUT THE PERSPECTIVE.
UNFORTUNATELY I BELIEVE WE'LL
HAVE YOU ON AGAIN TO TALK ABOUT
THE SAME PROBLEM.
IT IS